[MUSIC PLAYING]
MIKE PROCOPIO: Well,
hello, everyone.
And welcome to Google I/O 2022.
My name is Mike Procopio.
I'm a senior staff software
engineer here at Google.
And today, it's my pleasure
to be speaking with you
about extending Google
Workspace with AppSheet's
no-code platform
and Apps Script.
Let's have a quick
look about where we're
going today with today's talk.
We have five key pieces
that we'll touch on.
First is AppSheet, that's
Google's no-code platform.
Next is Google
Workspace, so properties
like Gmail, Calendar,
Drive, Docs, and Sheets.
We have Google Workspace APIs,
the Application Programmer
Interfaces that power,
each one of these
and enable
third-party developers
to programmatically
interact with Workspace.
We have Apps Script, which is
Google's low-code platform that
wraps those Google
Workspace APIs.
And then finally, we have what
we are previewing here today,
which is AppSheet's
Apps Script Connector,
an integration that connects
all of these together.
Let's talk about
Google's AppSheet.
I like to say that the
era of no-code is here.
And this comes from
the perspective
of watching programming
languages evolve over
many years.
The earliest programming
languages, as you may know,
were very rudimentary,
very low level,
and close to the processor.
Over time, these languages
got higher and higher level--
two languages, for example,
like Java and C++--
and then even higher level than
that, for example scripting
languages.
And if you take
this to the limit,
you end up in a
place that basically
looks like specifying things
using definition and semantics,
and not actual code.
How can we do this?
Well, it turns out that
many business applications
have similar structure, right?
Apps are built on a data source.
Users interact with them.
And so it's possible to build
a great variety of apps using
this general definition
of what the app should do,
as opposed to
actually writing code.
So AppSheet is Google's
no-code platform.
It's a fast way to build
apps and to automate work.
It lets an app
creator build an app
without actually
writing code, using
the definition of what the
app should do as opposed
to actual code.
Here's what that looks like
inside an actual editor.
So this is the experience
of the app creator.
And we are creating the app
using the app definition.
So instead of
actually coding, we're
basically saying what
the app should do.
So here in the middle, we're
building an automation,
and this is something that
will preview here shortly,
which says, when something
happens, do this other thing.
In this case, the
other thing is we're
going to call an
Apps Script function.
So that's one way
we can edit an app.
Another way is we can build
on top of a data source
and map the columns
inside the data source
to fields that the user sees
inside the app, and so on.
On the right-hand side,
we see a live preview
of what the app
actually looks like when
it's running, in this
case, the mobile version.
So one key thing that a no-code
platform needs to do well,
and that AppSheet does well,
is to automate workflows.
We sometimes refer
to this as bots.
What this basically means is
creating-- using a definition,
not code--
a set of expectations that
when an event happens,
we can listen for it and then
trigger some other action.
So for example,
concretely, when a user
creates a data row
inside the app,
then we can do this other
action-- for example,
sending an SMS text message
or an email for approval.
Another key thing that a
no-code platform needs to do
is to integrate with a
wide variety of services.
So for AppSheet, this means
inside Google, of course.
But it also means
a great variety
of third-party services.
Now, you can build
an AppSheet app
on top of a variety
of data sources,
including Office 365,
Dropbox, and Salesforce.
And then using Apps Script,
which we'll see here shortly,
you can then call into an
equally wide range of services,
including Google
and other services.
So Google Workspace is
Google's productivity suite
that has more than
3 billion users,
helping teams of all
sizes connect, create,
and collaborate.
So these are the apps
that we know fairly well--
Gmail, Docs, Sheets,
Slides, Calendar, and so on.
Behind each Google Workspace
app is also a mature API.
If we look back, we can see
many of the Google Workspace
applications, like Docs,
Sheets, and Slides,
date back over 15 years.
But what may be less clear
is that each one of those
has an API.
This lets an application
developer automatically
integrate with the Google
Workspace property.
So for example on
Drive, programmatically,
using the API, you can
upload and download files.
Or in Google Docs,
programmatically,
using the API,
application developer
can automatically add
text to a document
or edit text in a document.
Same goes with
Sheets and Slides.
For Calendar, you can create
a calendar appointment
automatically, and send it
out, and manage its responses,
and so on.
So we've seen the
Google Workspace APIs.
We also have Apps
Script at Google,
which is Google's low-code
development environment.
This lets an application
developer, among other things,
easily access the
Google Workspace
APIs from a high-level
perspective-- more
of a scripting language.
As we will see, this is really
key for the no-code space
because if you can connect the
no-code app with Apps Script,
you can greatly extend
the possibilities of what
the no-code app can do.
So a quick recap here.
Let's see, we have
four key pieces--
AppSheet, we've seen, is
Google's no-code platform;
Google Workspace-- that's
Gmail, Calendar, Drive, Docs,
Sheets, and Slide; the APIs
behind each of those Google
Workspace properties; and
then Apps Script, which
is Google's low-code platform
that wraps those Workspace
APIs, in addition to other
third-party services.
That brings us to our
core idea here today.
The AppSheet Apps
Script Connector.
And basically,
what this means is,
from the context of AppSheet,
a no-code environment,
an app creator now has access
to all of the functionality
that Apps Script provides.
But it's key to note that the
person building the AppSheet
app, the no-code environment,
isn't necessarily the person
who wrote the script.
So there has to
be a sensible way
to expose the Apps
Script script information
inside the no-code environment.
Here's what that looks like.
On the right, you can see
that the user has chosen
a script available to them--
in this case, the application
author.
We list out the parameters
that are required to pass
into that Apps Script function.
And then we simply bind them
to the data source on which
the AppSheet app is built.
So here are just a few use cases
for how this might be useful.
The use case that we'll focus
on today, including in the demo,
is to be able to create
an audit log by appending
a summary of changes that
happen inside the AppSheet app
to a separate data
source logging it
in a separate isolated
way-- in this case,
for demonstration purposes,
simply a Google Doc.
There are other
use cases, though.
For example, inside
Google Workspace
you can automate
Slides, for example,
adding a new slide every time a
personnel directory is updated,
creating and editing calendar
appointments, managing files
inside Google Drive,
or, equivalently,
calling an external service
to do something similar
with a different provider.
OK, so in this screenshot,
we see an actual picture
of the Apps Script Editor
creating a function
that ultimately, we will call
from a no-code application.
As noted before,
the person who works
in this environment,
this low-code environment
inside Apps Script, may
not be the same person
who's creating the no-code app.
In many cases, these
will be different.
And the skill sets
will also be different.
So let's take a look
at the actual code
that we'll see here in
the demonstration shortly.
This is an Apps Script function.
It's a working
piece of code that
shows what it looks like to
create a reference to a Google
Docs document, and then
take the parameters that
have been passed
into the function
and append them to the document.
So here we're using the Google
Docs API to automatically
script the content
in the document using
Apps Script and Apps
Script function, which
has data and is called by
an AppSheet Automation.
Let's take a look at what that
looks like from the perspective
of AppSheet.
As we noted before, the person
who wrote the Apps Script code
function doesn't
necessarily have
to be, in many cases
who actually won't be,
the person creating
the no-code app.
From the perspective
of the no-code app,
it's as simple as choosing
the Apps Script function
and then mapping in or binding
the values from the data
source on which the
AppSheet app is built
to the parameters
in the function
that we're calling
within Apps Script.
And this is what that looks
like, here on the right,
simply going down through
the list of the parameters
and mapping them one by one to
the columns and the data source
inside the no-code app.
OK, it's demo time.
We've seen AppSheet, Apps
Script, Google Workspace,
and the Google Workspace APIs.
Here's a demo of a use
case that we saw before,
where we create an audit log
as a result of some trigger
inside the AppSheet app.
We do this by calling
an Apps Script function.
Hello, and welcome to the
demo for the Apps Script
Connector for AppSheet.
In today's demo,
we'll see step-by-step
how to call an Apps Script
function from AppSheet.
We'll see how to set this up
using an AppSheet Automation
and how to pass in parameters to
the Apps Script function using
the Expression Assistant.
For this demo, we'll be
using the Travel Request
tool, an AppSheet Demo app.
This app is used for managing
employee travel requests
inside an organization.
Using the app, an employee
will create a travel request,
which will then be sent
to a manager for approval.
So the travel request
contains fields
such as flight information,
cost, business purpose,
and other details.
In any no-code app,
there may be times
when an app needs additional
capabilities beyond what
a no-code platform can provide.
The Apps Script Connector
that we're demoing here today
greatly extends the
abilities of AppSheet apps
by letting them access the power
of Apps Script and all the APIs
and services that
it integrates with.
In this demo, we'll use the
App Script Connector to call
a function in Apps Script.
This function calls
the Google Docs API
to append travel request
details to a Google Doc, which
creates a simple audit log.
This function will be called
from an AppSheet Automation
that triggers
whenever a new travel
request is created in the app.
In this demo, we have
three key players.
First is the AppSheet Editor,
shown here on the left.
This shows the app definition
for the Travel Request tool
and also a live preview of the
app on the right-hand side.
Next we have the Apps Script
Development Environment,
shown in the upper
right, which is
where we'll be editing the
function that we're calling.
And finally in the bottom right,
we see the Google Doc itself,
the audit log,
which we will update
in real time via Apps Script
whenever we create a new travel
request in AppSheet.
Let's get started.
The Travel Request tool is
already built and shown here
in the AppSheet Editor.
The first step in
calling Apps Script
is to create an automation
in the AppSheet app.
To do this, we select the
Automation tab, and then
click New Bot.
The bot will listen
for an event,
in this case, whenever
a new requests record is
created using the app.
When that happens, the
automation will call a process,
and in that process will create
a special Call a Script task.
Now let's expand that task where
we can configure the details
for calling the script.
To configure the
script, we'll first
choose the Apps Script Project.
We have this created already.
It's the script shown in the
upper right in the Apps Script
Editor.
This script has been
saved to Google Drive,
and so we can select that here.
Once selected, a list of
available functions in the Apps
Script Project will appear.
Choose the function to call.
In this case, there's
only one function,
called Log Travel
Request Update.
We'll choose that one.
Once the function
is selected, a list
of parameters needed to
call it will be populated.
So in this case,
that includes details
like request date, requester,
travel origin, and destination,
and so on.
You can see this matches
the expected function
signature shown in Apps Script.
Next we'll use AppSheet's
built in Expression Assistant
to choose which values
in the underlying data
source to pass as the
function parameters.
Here, we'll simply
map each parameter
to a single column
in the data source.
So that includes ID, date,
requester, origin, destination,
and purpose.
And that's it.
Click Save, and now
let's test our work.
To do that, we'll
add a new record
using the live
preview of the app
here on the right side
of the AppSheet editor.
We'll just create a sample
travel request, in this case,
flying from Denver to San Jose.
We'll add in the details,
such as departure and arrival
dates and business purpose.
Note that not all of these
will be part of the auto log.
Now, let's save this record
and then sync the app.
This will trigger the
automation we created earlier,
calling the Apps Script
function using information
from the travel request
that we just added.
The function uses
the Google Docs API
to directly edit the
Google Docs file, which
is shown in the bottom right.
This typically takes a
few seconds to execute,
which happens in the background
on AppSheet's servers.
And there it is.
The details of
the travel request
are added to the Google
Doc in real time.
From here, we could add
in additional parameters
to the Apps Script
function or even
extend it to use other APIs
or services available in Apps
Script, like YouTube,
BigQuery, Google Analytics,
or other external service.
Well that concludes our demo.
Thank you for watching our
demo for the Apps Script
Connector for AppSheet.
We can't wait to
see what you build.
OK, so we've just seen the
demo of creating an audit
log using an Apps
Script function called
from an AppSheet no-code app
as a result of an automation.
Let's take a look at next steps.
Great first step for beginning
to work with AppSheet
and no-code in general is
to join the AppSheet Creator
Community.
And then once you've
done that and you've
created your first
AppSheet no-code app,
you can try out the
Apps Script integration.
And linked here
is the Help Center
and the docs and tutorials
that will help you get started.
And then finally, we have
an excellent how-to video
that gives a different
take and a different use
case for how to
call an Apps Script
function from the context
of an AppSheet no-code app.
Well, thank you, everyone.
On the right-hand side,
you'll see some links
to some additional resources.
I'm Mike Procopio.
It's been my pleasure
to speak with you today
about AppSheet and Apps
Script integration.
And I hope you have a great
rest of your Google I/O 2022.
[MUSIC PLAYING]